[Music]
it's seven o'clock this is sky news
tonight our top story a red alert for
the new covid variant from health
officials a new risk analysis of the
omicron variant gives more details on
how easily it might be transmitted and
whether it could evade vaccines
prime minister should people go ahead
with christmas party plans
will you be having a christmas party
prime minister
a thumbs up from the prime minister over
whether festive celebrations should
still go ahead but casey's top 50 000
for the second day in a row while coming
up we'll be trying to answer all your
pressing questions on the omicron
variant of our panel of experts also
tonight a father and his partner are
jailed for abusing and killing
six-year-old arthur lebinjo hughes
[Music]
the entire coaching staff at yorkshire
county cricket club leave in the wake of
azim rafiq's racism allegations
the fa apologizes after a review says
lives could have been lost when fans
stormed the euro 2020 final at wembley
more than four years on from the
grenfell fire we speak to leaseholders
desperate for help to make their
building safe
and we chat to oscar winner olivia
coleman about her latest role as a real
life manager
[Music]
a very good evening i'm jonathan samuels
the omicron covid variant is still
providing more questions than answers
for scientists tonight but new analysis
from the uk health security agency has
started to fill in some of the gaps in
our knowledge it's issued a red alert on
the variant on its ability in theory to
evade both vaccines and naturally
acquired immunity but scientists stress
any predictions are difficult to be sure
of at the moment meanwhile the general
uk covid situation continues to be of
concern as daily cases passed 50 000 for
the second successive day all of which
poses another set of questions for
politicians with the prime minister
again pressed today on whether christmas
celebrations should go ahead well coming
up we'll be speaking to our panel of
experts who'll be on hand to answer your
questions but first let's get a bit more
detail on what new information we've got
about omicron today we can speak to our
health correspondent ashish jose joshi
so are she scientists racing to
understand more about omicron what is
the latest
well every case jonathan will give our
scientists and researchers a little bit
more information and when you have a
cluster of cases
it gives you an indication but i ought
to stress right now that this is just
too small
a data set to form any judgments on this
gives us indications it gives us an idea
of the way that this variant might be
behaving let's go through some of those
numbers that have been given to us by
the uk health security agency
it says 12 of the 22 known cases up to
november the 30th had been fully
vaccinated so that's almost
half right that's 12 of the 22 known
cases that's over half of the cases had
been fully vaccinated another two had
been given their first dose at least
four weeks earlier
six were unvaccinated with no data
available on the other two cases so just
that small sample shows you that a large
number of those people who had omicron
were vaccinated were double vaccinated
as far as the 12 were concerned had been
fully vaccinated and the other two have
been given their first dose so on the
surface of it
they are quite concerning those numbers
because you you would have thought that
the vaccine would have offered you more
protection against omicron but i ought
to stress that this is a very small
sample this is 22 people then it goes on
to say that the uk health
security agency says there is a strong
early signal of omicron cases in the uk
and that it knows from the pcr tests
it's conducting this is looking for a an
s gene drop out which is indicative of
vomicon but also
some other variants but certainly the
early indication is that there are there
is a rise in the number of omicron cases
and the the um
signal the red alert you were talking
about earlier
it says the uk hsa has given the highest
red alert against the virus again we
will stress for its theoretical ability
based on mutations
to evade both the vaccine and naturally
acquired immunity and it also says the
risk assessment gives it an amber alert
for transmissibility which is expected
to be at least as high
as other
variants currently circulating but it
also goes on to say and remember this is
for the time for the period up to
november the 21st monitoring of
wastewater has found very little
evidence of omicron you would expect
that to increase as more cases are found
so on this surface
it does seem like there is a degree of
vaccine evasion in this variant and that
would seem to be what is suggested by
the data in south africa too
okay much more work to be done before we
have a full picture of course ashish for
the moment thank you well we can take a
look at the latest daily covid data now
there have been 50
584
new cases of kovid 19 recorded in the
last 24 hours another 143 deaths have
been reported within 28 days of a
positive test and that brings the total
number of deaths in the uk to 145
4424 now 25 848 people received their
first dose of a vaccine while 30 976
people received their second dose that
means the total number of people to have
received their second dose is now more
than 46.4 million and 420 910 booster
and third jabs were given in the latest
24-hour period taking the total number
of those doses to more than 19.4 million
well the nationwide infection rate now
stands at 440 weekly cases per 100 000
people virtually unchanged in fact from
a week ago the place with the highest
case rate is still torridge in devon
with 1059 cases per 100 000. aside from
the scottish islands the place with the
lowest rate is carlyle in cumbria 223
cases per 100 000 people there
well routine health checks for over 75s
may be deferred because of the pressure
on the nhs caused by plans to accelerate
the covid booster program it comes as
ministers face more pressure on whether
christmas parties can go ahead in the
face of the new omicron coveted variant
ministers have today insisted that
people should carry on as normal and the
prime minister gave a thumbs up when
questioned on the issue in downey street
in the past hour the prime minister has
been speaking about the variant and
christmas let's have a listen
on the subject of christmas parties i
noticed there's been quite a lot of
chewing and throwing about it
people concerned that and they need to
cancel their christmas parties that's
not right we're not saying that and
we're not saying that nativity plays
have to be cancelled i believe very
strongly that kids should be in school
and i also think that uh that christmas
should go ahead as normally as possible
what we're trying to do is cope with the
the omicron variant and that means
having some tough measures at the
borders
and also some measures to make sure that
people isolate if they're coming in
contact with a nominal case plus we're
toughening up the measures on on masks
and that's a balanced and proportionate
approach to take to omicron whilst we
wait to to get to the bottom of uh of
exactly the risk that it poses but key
point key point
whatever the risk omicron may pose or
may not pose the booster is everywhere
and always going to be or vaccination is
going to be your best protection
our correspondent ali fortescue is here
with me in the studio the prime minister
speaking in the last hour or so uh ali
pretty much carry on as normal when it
comes to christmas planning of course
there is this huge push isn't there now
for the for the booster program and
there is concern that that's going to
divert nhs staff away from what is
always a very busy period yeah that's
right and i think all week we've heard
warnings from gps about staff shortages
we know that the government want to
vaccinate half a million people a day as
part of that ramping up the booster
campaign right back to where we were at
the height of the first rollout of the
vaccine so obviously that's an enormous
logistical challenge and things are
going to have to be moved around and
we've seen a letter from the nhs today
that's been sent to gps um to
psychiatrists it says
that routine checks for over 70s could
be deferred which i think has prompted
some concerns because obviously there's
already a backlog there's already
worries about staff shortages but i've
been told that um face-to-face
appointments still going to be able to
go ahead so if someone over 75 has a
worry they will easily i'm told bl to
book an appointment um and i've also
been told that some non-urgent
procedures could be suspended the
examples i was given were things like
routine weight checks for people with
serious mental health illness that could
be um suspended or the way that asthma
is diagnosed we have to have two
diagnoses so
some things could be pushed back for the
next few months until the end of march
is what we understand
but the royal college psychiatrists have
said that these are
sensible and temporary measures um but i
think there is definitely a focus on the
next few weeks over how the nhs copes
with this massive booster campaign when
it's already under a lot of strain in
the winter yeah of course very
interesting okay ali thank you very much
for that now we asked you this afternoon
to send in your questions about the
omicron kovid variant many of you did
thank you for that let's try to get some
of the answers then from our expert
panel they are jeffrey orman visiting
professor of microbiology at the
university of oxford and adviser to the
government's vaccine task force also dr
claudia paoloni president of the
hospital consultants and specialist
association and the consultant aneetha
tist and ravi gupta professor of
clinical microbiology at the cambridge
institute for therapeutic immunology and
infectious diseases wonderfully long
titles they all have and we are
delighted to see you this evening thank
you very much indeed well let's get
cracking then on some of these questions
um starting perhaps with uh dr paulini
if that's okay following on from the
prime minister's comments i'm sure you
heard them a short time ago this
question from frank sandum now he says
in insisting that christmas will be
better than last year and to keep calm
and carry on hasn't the government left
themselves nowhere to go
if the omicron variant turns out to be
really
serious what are your thoughts on that
well i think it is
quite a difficult situation at the
moment because we don't know enough
about the the the new variant
um
but if you were to take a precautionary
stance you really would question whether
we should be encouraging people to do
too much social mixing but it is a
really difficult
difficult situation to judge right now
yeah professor almonds what are your
thoughts about about christmas about the
restrictions as they stand um we are in
this sort of watch and wait zone aren't
we it is difficult to to make policy
we are in the watch and wait period
until we know a little more about the
old micron and whether it's going to
really evade the immunity we've got
through vaccination
um we've got to be very cautious and i i
think at the moment we're trying to sort
of balance
the response to say be careful maintain
your
the social measures the mask wearing and
so on without a real clamp down um
we're all fed up with this we all want
to have a nice christmas but
this is now here we've got to deal with
it i think if we learn in the next few
days or the next week or so that it is
really um more severe than we feared and
it really does escape immunity i'm sure
the government will take even you know
commensurate measures and even tighter
um precautions yeah it's interesting
professor gupta isn't it that uh this
evening we've seen ireland bring in more
restrictions
yeah so you know the the the issue here
is of course that uh we've learned that
once you realize there's a problem it's
often
somewhat too late to act because of
course uh transmission has gone that
much further it's penetrated the
community the vulnerable in the
community um
you know have been exposed to the virus
and therefore it's difficult to bring it
under control without really quite
extreme measures so and this is the kind
of dilemma being faced and of course the
timing couldn't be any worse
as we go up to the the the um
festive season
but i would say that with uh an expanded
vaccination campaign and really uh we
could have probably done a better job of
expanding uh vaccinations through out
the age groups and uh reinforcing
boosters in a much bigger way
with a sense of urgency over summer when
we had the opportunity and unfortunately
i think we are probably now in a
position where we're looking back
wondering whether we did enough
um
so so that's just one thing to say no
it's not necessarily criticism but it's
really just a lesson for us all
to
to to make gains while we can in in this
fight against coronavirus and of course
uh the use of um face cover is
absolutely essential to limit
transmission of any variant and that's
the key thing about face masks they
don't have to be high tech they they
just work and they can be used by large
numbers of people in crowded spaces to
good effect as um data have shown so
really it's up to policy makers to
decide what to do but we do have the
tools we've had the tools for a long
time and really we should be learning
from our mistakes yeah the government of
course would say that uh they have set
this incredible challenge for the nhs to
offer boosters to all adults in just 62
uh days but maybe maybe as you say it
could have been done a little bit
earlier all right let's move on to our
second question uh this is from gillian
walker i'll get you professor allman to
start off on this one um i have been in
the clinically extremely vulnerable
group and are now fully covered
vaccinated including the booster my
question is will it be safe for me to
attend a family funeral service next
week or should i watch the online
broadcast that question from julian
it depends how um
how populated the family funeral is and
whether she's confident that uh other
members there are all um triply or
doubly vaccinated uh and are cautious um
i
i myself am in a vulnerable group and uh
but triply vaccinated uh and i'm just
being careful um i will attend a small
group of family but i wouldn't go to
nightclubs or or busy bars for example
so i think it it's a question of
judgment there if if the group is small
you know the people you know they've
recently been jabbed then i would say
you you're probably quite safe to attend
such a thing but if it's a big gathering
a lot of people from all over the
country
then be very careful indeed okay that's
good good advice um claudia it's
interesting uh isn't it the breaking
news tonight that over half of uk
omicron cases are in people who have had
two jabs this coming from the uk health
security agency um two vulnerable people
that sort of information does sound
alarming but of course there are loads
of caveats aren't there
yeah it's difficult because also you
have to remember that the vaccination
program started really early we did
really well with that so well this is
why it's so important to get the
boosters now because something that the
immunity that will have
been achieved through the double
vaccinations that people have
experienced will be starting to wane so
the best defense that we've got
is for everyone to get their booster um
as soon as possible so that they can
re-boost that immunity up so if you're
clinically vulnerable or otherwise
you've got more protection than if you
wait too long and especially for all
those who aren't vaccinated or those
people who've only gone part way as
those numbers shown that we have a real
problem here with um the the potential
because we don't know enough about the
varies but we've got a problem with the
potential of if it's very transmissible
or more transmissible it will be a
numbers game more people will be
infected which means from our point of
view from staff side of
in hospitals
they won't be able to come to work
because they'll have to self-isolate now
with the omicron whether they're double
vaccinated triple vaccinated it won't
matter they'll have to self-isolate that
will put additional pressure on the
hospitals so
we have to really encourage everyone to
get that community immunity
as high as possible
because that is our best defense for all
of us and for the hospitals as well
okay well i've got a vaccine uh question
now perhaps uh uh ravi gupta you can you
can have a go at this one uh it's from
chris he says i've had both first and
second vaccine astrazeneca he had and
i've had my booster which was a pfizer
i'm on immunotherapy how protected am i
from this variant omicron and past
variants um interesting i was reading if
you've had that sequence if you've had
the two astrazeneca jabs and then a
pfizer jab that's that's a pretty good
cocktail um uh in terms of uh um
fighting the the virus
yes so certainly uh astrazeneca followed
by um or adenovirus vectored vaccine
followed by rna vector vax or delivered
vaccine is
has been shown to give a very good uh
response after third days we don't know
how long that lasts of course so so so
that's uh a slight unknown but yes you
do achieve really good neutralization
titus even though two doses of chadox on
their own often uh lead to slightly um
lower or somewhat lower um neutralizing
antibody titans so um it's a difficult
question with this with immunotherapy it
depends what the immunotherapy is what
it's for
what the underlying means progression is
uh difficult to give clinical advice uh
on television so one would have to be
careful here and say that it's it you
know it it depends on what the response
is and how severe the immune depression
is so and i think this but this case
does highlight a
uh an important um aspect which is that
you know we we do practice personalized
medicine to some degree and we should be
offering patients the opportunity to
have their immune response tested uh in
a standardized way and i think we could
do that so that people do understand
their risk and their doctors understand
the risk this will be important as we go
forward considering fourth doses for
example and uh further types of
vaccination as we get more sophisticated
so i think we do need to start having
the conversation about
individuals knowing their response
status uh uh earlier rather than later
because it will become an issue later
anyway
okay very good point um professor almond
this is something i've actually been
thinking about i had my booster
in the last few days i've now had four
jabs this year three uh vaccines plus a
flu jab um we didn't get a name from
this anonymous texter but they're asking
how many jabs can we actually have can
we max out our antibodies
uh no i don't think so when you're when
you're a child you have mumps measles
rubella diphtheria pertussis polio um
and some areas will have hepatitis b and
haemophilus as well um and then as you
get into adulthood you you may well have
also um
the papillomavirus vaccine uh so
and when you meet infections when you
catch a cold or you you have any other
infectious disease illness of course
your immune response is kicked into
action so there's no limit really um to
to what um you know what you can respond
to
there may be limits but but to all
intents and purposes you can respond to
many different uh vaccines and yeah none
of us want to become pincushions but i
don't think we have to worry about not
being able to respond to three four or
five or six shots
okay that's uh that that's uh that's
good to know very useful um dr paulini
uh uh i suppose um on on the on the
vaccine issue we know in south africa
that only about 25 of people have been
double vaccinated and it's interesting
that there's been this surge hasn't
there in people getting covered multiple
times why do you think that is
uh there could also be the fact that
there is a higher hiv population so they
could be immunocompromised as well so we
don't know enough about that detail
either um
it's a shame that there's only a success
rate of about 25 of the vaccination um
that will have an impact on its spread
as well so but but again we don't know
how much of an impact on
transmissibility being vaccinated um
will actually protect us but fall um and
that's
that's what we're waiting for the
initial evidence that came out today
would suggest perhaps um there is a
problem with that
yeah um what about um 50 000 cases again
for the second consecutive day ravi
gupta are you concerned about that
we've had uh
case numbers in this ballpark for some
time now and
it clearly has had um an impact on uh
obviously health services but also we've
lost you know quite a large number of
lives and we've had significant
morbidity and knock-on effects on other
services and ambulance weights etc that
we all know about
um so i i certainly am not somebody who
thinks that we've had a good run in the
last few months
and uh
really we have now perfect conditions
for a new
variant to seed and expand at a
significant rate
and this new variance may be
worse for us than the delta we should i
should stress though that the delta
variant
is already able to uh break through
vaccine and that you can become infected
uh despite vaccination with delta and
that's potentially because of its very
high infectivity as well as some partial
immune invasions so it's not that the
omicron is doing something completely
new we have seen this before and uh
therefore
you know it's not necessarily a
um
you know a very very bad sign so it just
depends on how much uh immune function
is left over in other words which bits
of the virus we can still recognize with
our immunity and and therefore target to
prevent uh progression to severe disease
and i think that with uh with boosting
uh and uh and and of course uh
completing vaccination in every and as
many people as possible you know we can
get to a situation where we minimize
morbidity immortality the other thing to
bear mind is of course you know that the
data
you know you you
mentioned of half the people being
double vaccinated well of course in a
population which is
where where the adults are are are
in the vast majority vaccinated of
course you're going to see uh any
viruses or positive diagnoses in
vaccinated people you know
statistically so
you know we do need to bear that in mind
when we um when we interpret the
findings of course we we anticipate this
as an escape virus we know this has been
done before and so we shouldn't be too
surprised that we're seeing it in
vaccinated individuals yeah so you make
a very good point you know 80 of the uk
uh population uh double vaccinated and
and uh obviously 50 000 people are
getting it in a day the vast majority of
them will be vaccinated and won't become
seriously ill or indeed go to hospital
which is is the good news okay another
question then dr paolini one for you if
an update to the vaccine to deal with
omicron is developed in the next 100
days and i've already had two
vaccinations and the booster would
people like me be required to take a
fourth injection as soon as possible or
could we wait till sometime in 2022 for
a yearly top-up that comes from stephen
lewis
i think again we still don't know enough
about the current vaccine
sorry current variant to to be able to
answer that i expect we will be needing
boosters every year for the foreseeable
future um of course even if they were
able to make and find the um the the new
vaccine which of course they will be
because that's one of the beauties of
these new mrna vaccines um it will be
then a production pro issue of how can
you produce it in enough quantity and
then distribute it um but i suspect we
will all be needing to be boosted in in
in due course and um it may well be next
winter it may will be sooner but it's
too early to judge that yeah
okay now here's a very good question
this is from dave in doncaster uh
professor allman perhaps you can have a
go at this one um can you have delta and
omicron together can you have them both
at the same time
absolutely yes
your polio vaccine is a mixture of three
the current flu vaccine actually is a
mixture of four
and some pneumonia vaccines are a
mixture of 15. it gets complicated when
we get up to those numbers but certainly
you can mix
delta and omicron together now the
danger of course is that by the time we
get three or four years down the road
we've gone from two to three to four to
five to six and we've got a complex
mixture that we're administering and we
would rather not do that the logistics
the manufacturing the formulation
getting balanced immune responses to
each component is is quite a challenge
actually um so you'd you'd rather keep
it simple
and if the emerging situation is for
coast circulating strains of delta top
of a micron and then
whatever comes
next epsilon or zeta or whatever it's
going to be
if we have to then go to four five six
and seven that is a pretty lousy
scenario if they all keep circulating if
other if some of them disappear we can
drop that one out of the vaccine but yes
we have the potential to be bivalent as
we say or trivalent or quadrivalent and
certainly they can be mixed or they can
be administered
yeah so when it comes to the vaccine you
could you could be injected with with
lots of different variants but what
about actually catching it from from two
different people one with the omicron
one with the delta is that is that
possible
well again that that depends a little
bit on what the cross protection is one
to another it would be unlikely um to
get both together
and and if you did get both um i i
it's not obvious that you'd be twice as
ill if i can put it that way
but if if the strains are sufficiently
different in principle you could have
both at the same time but that would be
quite unlikely
and you'd probably bring them under
control with some sort of cross-reactive
responses particularly cellular
responses um around the same time
brilliant a very detailed uh answer uh
for dave in doncaster um and what about
this one uh ravi gupta perhaps you can
answer this for us if scientists are
still studying the viruses behavior and
do not know much about it yet how come
the british government made the decision
to reduce the time needed in between the
second shot and booster shots and make
them available to anyone over the age of
18 when there isn't enough scientific
data available to know if this course of
action will work i mean that is
something that's changed but if it felt
very rapidly that that time
difference between the two jabs
so the answer to that is quite clear um
and it's come from some of the big
studies conducted in the uk israel and
the us and and that uh and the data
there are that
after this dose the the responses uh as
determined by your antibodies and and to
some lesser extent t cell responses due
to start declining off to the second
month so um as of two months after your
second dose you are in a sort of
declining sort of um part of your
response and therefore boosting um after
that two months will um maintain uh
levels of of of protective immunity uh
and to prevent that decline and we know
that that decline during high
transmission that we have in the uk is
associated with greater morbidity and
mortality in the elderly in particular
so these declining responses do have a
clinical impact in some individuals and
we want to avoid that so this is this is
information derived from from delta
variance infection infections but we can
extrapolate that we may have a similar
scenario or if or worse still with
omicron and therefore i think it's a
sensible decision to bring
those boosters forward and to vaccinate
as many adults as possible and indeed uh
into the the
children as well
okay uh fantastic well i feel like we've
learnt a great deal tonight so many
questions so many answers we don't yet
know but of course we will get more
information as the days pass but i thank
you all very much indeed your expert
analysis professor jeffrey orman dr
claudia paulini and also professor ravi
gupta great to see you all and we
appreciate your time this friday evening
and indeed thank you to you if you did
email us and text us a question
apologies if we didn't get round to
yours you're watching sky news tonight
coming up after the break emma tustin
and thomas hughes are sentenced for the
killing of his six-year-old son arthur
[Music]
[Music]
foreign